tél
[Musique]
espace de boulot on dit noir c'est une
image mais non rien ne s'échappe
impossible de savoir qu'est ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur d'un trou noir
puisque par définition aucune
information aucun signal lumineux aucune
onde radio aucun électromagnétiques rien
qui peut en sortir
donc ça va rester pour toujours un
mystère absolu
sauf évidemment d'un point de vue
théorique parce que là on est capable
avec un crayon à papier avec des grosses
simulation numérique aussi essayé
d'imaginer de comprendre ce que c'est
dans notre petit langage on appelle ça
un trou noir supermassif ça fait un peu
comme un super héros mais ça vous montre
bien que il est extrêmement gros pour un
trou noir d'accord c'est à dire qu'on
est en train de paris de plusieurs
millions ou de plusieurs milliards de
fois la masse du soleil soleil c'est
très gros dégâts
donc c'est vraiment de ces des monstres
1,6 des monstres
et
[Musique]
oui